the main stories but witches see true  what they say elves are the original  sorceress of the continent when humans  and monsters arrived else taught us how  to count chaos into magic the humans  looked at them  chaos is the most dangerous thing in  this world  without control chaos will kill you  so that's all like this to you monsters  and money it's all it needs to me  something out there weights fee  this child will be extraordinary  Jennifer imagine the most powerful woman  in the world  do you have what it takes  you can't outrun destiny just because  you're terrified of it it's coming  I can't do this without you  no matter what you choose  you'll come out bloody  you  you